how did this happen bro Oho look at that
brother and sisters check this out yeah
yes come here come here bro the keys are
in the ignition the the keys are in the
ignition
yeah brother how do you manage to do
that from the road did he hit anyone
else he hit that white yarus and flipped
bro look at this guys look at this yeah
do you know how many people brother and
sisters do not make it to
Ramadan I am a Reaver and I was taught
how to pray Salah that means every
single time I pray the person who told
me gets the reward five times a day from
F to is if you want to support someone
like me in learning Salah then sponsor
10 people for just 00 this Ramadan
remember the prophet peace be upon him
said charity does not decrease wealth
click the button and donate
now guys so basically we are on our way
to meet a brother yesterday a non-muslim
who donated £500 to our Sal's budget and
then he called in randomly and then he
took sh we was on the way to go see him
because going hand deliver a um guided
prayer mat but as we was driving came
across
this we walk fast yeah thank you it
wasn't me I didn't do it walk slowly
though Stand where hands up please give
me a date yes I'm talking about I hit
the car doesn't matter see we've got the
police offic the very police off
how did this happen bro oh look at that
so brother and sisters here check this
out yeah let come here come here bro the
keys are in the ignition the the keys
are in ignition
yeah brother how do you manage to do
that when the RO did he hit anyone else
he hit that white Yaris and think
flipped bro look at this guy look at
this yeah look behind me look at this
car it's F over I don't even know how
they managed to do that I want I want to
speak to the guy and ask him how he
manage to do this cuz that's that's
that's that being you know creative or
think but Jo the side guys inside we're
in Ramadan do you know how many people
brother and sisters do not make it to
Ramadan come yes Soh Allah finally
enough I was like how did they end up do
that it was a Muslim brother who
actually was listening to the Quran
can't remember what happened hits the
the Middle Island and he flips the
camera uh the car flips Subhan Allah he
was a Muslim brother and we thought
somebody just you know drunk driving or
whatever it is is just crashed and leave
in the car and run away it's a genuine
accident and he came me just spoke to me
said please bro don't have my face I
said yeah have your face but subh Allah
and I was just thinking to myself you
know Allah says in the Quran we send a
small Calamity to divert a bigger
Calamity and what does that mean it
means that if Allah knows that you are
committing sins you're committing sins
you're committing sins Allah sends a
Calamity it can be an accident it can be
a loss of love one it can be a business
transaction that goes haywi or whatever
it is for that matter so that that
little Calamity diverse you from the
bigger calamity meaning if you follow
that way of doing sins or whatever it is
for that matter Subhan Allah that you
will end up in the Hellfire so Allah
sends that small look at the blessings
look how merciful Allah is that he sends
a small Calamity it can be something
like this that can draw you closer to
Allah alhamd the brother had an accident
he said I'm someone that's already
practicing I said it can be that Allah
wants you to draw closer to him to him
inah and he said yeah of course I said
is going to be different today and he
said yeah yes he was laughing he the way
you're going to pray Salah today he's
not going to be the way you prayed Salah
before and this is the things that keep
us on check and that's why said it is
calamities that keep us on check
brothers and sisters and Allah says in
the Quran Allah does not change the
condition of man until man changes
what's within himself and the scholars
understands in two ways number one Allah
does not change your condition meaning
you're sinning Allah will not give you
blessings and change your way for the
better unless you change what within
yourself and the scholars say you can
also understand this in a different way
which is what Allah will not change your
condition meaning Allah will bless you
with all the blessings until you start
sinning then Allah will change your
condition to the worst so Subhan Allah
it is so profound brothers and sisters
it works both ways but it's a reminder
for us this can happen to any any any of
us yeah these accidents Etc I involed
accident Subhan Allah and it is a wake
up call it brings you closer to Islam
brothers and sisters and closer to your
lord we ask Allah subh to protect the
brother and I told him download your app
do your morning and even it protects you
against these kind of things against
your
against and all this kind of stuff the
brother was okay may Allah bless and
protect him but anyway we saw this we a
reminder for Ramadan in guys and that's
we're going to head off as we told you
guys the brother who accepted with us
Ryan we're going to go see him inallah
and give him a guided prayer mat and
brother and sisters if you want to
support the project the link is there in
for the sake of Allah we are going to
head off in but yes